[Musique]
donc à ce que la réunion marseillais et
merci je suis contente d'être ici c'est
dany
c'est un petit village où il fait bon
vivre
mon père vient du village d'à côté il
fatigue et ma mère d'un type que
nous avons des plages avec du sable
blanc immaculé
mon père et ma mère sont mauvaises nous
prenons la mer tous les jours
ah oui la pêche c'est notre spécialité
veut cumule toutes les activités la
coiffure la pêche et le rugby
filez harpon plongé je sais tout faire
ni
[Musique]
we can des moins jeunes
j'étais une élève très studieuse mais je
n'ai pas pu continuer les études j'ai dû
arrêter très tôt mes parents ne
pouvaient plus continuer à payer les
dépenses liées à ma scolarité
d'autant que l'école était très éloigné
de notre maison quand j'ai arrêté les
études j'avais un petit ami je suis
tombée enceinte
quand mon fils cristiano avait un an
j'ai découvert le rugby c'est le rugby
qui m'a permis de m'épanouir d'élargir
mon horizon
ça m'a passionné
ensuite j'ai fait une formation de
coiffure
j'ai reçu mon certificat professionnel
en 2021
et je continue aussi à des activités
liées à la pêche
[Musique]
effectivement avant je n'osais même pas
m'exprimer j'étais renfermé mais après
le rugby je n'hésite plus à dire les
choses à donner mon opinion à dénoncer
des injustices à conseiller les jeunes
qui en ont besoin
pieroni de l'association terre en mêlée
a organisé une formation chez nous dans
le sud
j'y ai trouvé mon compte car je me
disais comme je n'ai pas pu aller loin
dans les études je vais foncer dans ce
sport que j'aime pour pouvoir aller le
plus loin possible dans ma vie
on n'a plus arrêté et beaucoup d'enfants
ont suivi nos traces
en 2017 nous étions 12 à former la
sélection dénommé code sapphire
nous avions à un tournoi dans la
capitale antananarivo
où nous avions montré de quoi nous
sommes capables
nous sommes les champions
de la coupe notamment
oui personne ne s'y attendait mais nous
avons montré que nous sommes des thèses
la jeune fille
toujours grâce au rugby je ne crains
plus rien
j'étais à l'aise devant la caméra alors
que je n'osais pas du tout m'exprimer
pendant le tournage on a beaucoup parlé
de notre quotidien a hand sceptre
de l'abondance des poissons des
activités en mer
le film a été tourné par christophe 20
10 à qui on a expliqué qu au retour des
pêches on se contente de ce qu'on reçoit
au quotidien
même si on ne revient qu'avec un kilo on
emmène vendre au marché
[Musique]
mahjoub à la réunion au japon
dubaï
maurice france
non ce n'est pas vrai raison pour
laquelle je multiplie les témoignages
partout où je passe
le sport n'est pas réservé aux hommes
les femmes sont capables de faire tout
ce que les hommes peuvent pas courir
dans certains foyers des hommes se
montrent violents et refusent de faire
les tâches ménagères sous prétexte
qu'ils sont fatigués pour avoir
travaillé toute la journée
et les femmes aux ménages aussi n'ont
cessé de travailler
donc la corvée de l'eau et les tâches
pénibles doivent être partagées et ne
sont pas réservés aux femmes c'est ça
l'égalité il met en fête à outils nos
empreintes d'un douanes même dit à fiona
l'âne
n'y a pas besoin
je leur dis tant que vos parents peuvent
vous envoyer à l'école et que vous avez
la chance de continuer vos études
persévérer ne vous découragez pas qu'un
les études permettent d'aller le plus
loin possible dans la vie
j'en parle même si je n'avais pas eu la
chance de finir mes études
alors je ne serai pas de répéter sachez
saisir la chance que vous avez
des fois les jeunes baisse les bras face
à des problèmes mineurs comme le fait de
ne pas avoir d'argent de poche pour le
goûter par exemple je répète soyez
courageux le résultat n'arrive pas dans
l'immédiat mais plus tard vous vous
rendrez compte de l'importance des
études et des efforts que vous déployez
cette qualification ne remplit de joie
elle donne du sens et du crédit à notre
sport
ça doit être une grande fierté pour tout
madagascar d'y participer pour la
première fois
merci au département de la réunion
merci à tous pour votre écoute
[Musique]